qui est qu'est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
vient d'abord quand quand un romancier
un un bon roman c'est un pour vous un
pour vous quand un romancier un projet
de roman en tête qu'est ce qu'il vient
d'abord allé à l'esprit un un contenu ou
bien au contraire une façon de raconter
et c'est parce que quand vous dites il
faut que les deux soient bons les
données la définition de leurs
classiques dont la forme et le contenu
était à l'unisson etc ça vient ensemble
ça vient l'un après l'autre et si ça
vienne l'un après l'autre lequel vient
d'abord je suis majine que ça vient
ensemble ou presque ensemble que la
préoccupation de la forme vient tout
naturellement à l'esprit de l'écrivain
que c'est une préoccupation qui est
souvent d'ailleurs influencé par
l'époque à laquelle il écrit qu'elle
peut être différente selon les temps
parce qu'il ya des mains dans
littérature il y a peut être un mode
d'expression qui domine à tel ou tel
moment et est ce que vous pensez que les
crises 1 au moment où il commence à
écrire est conscient de ce que sera la
signification son livre au moment où il
commence le livre probablement pas
entièrement il a fini quand il a fini
peut-être ne le sait-il pas encore
toujours moi j'irai alors plus loin dans
ce sens là et ça finira par dire
exactement le contraire de ce que vous
avez dit l'écrivain n'est pas quelqu'un
qui a conscient dans la tête
le sujet son livre l'écrivain est à la
recherche de quelque chose il est à la
recherche lui-même est à la recherche du
monde il est à la recherche de lui même
il est à la recherche de quelque chose
et cette recherche va prendre cette
forme l'exercice problématique de la
littérature comme disait georges est pas
donc ça ne va pas être une recherche
conceptuelle cédera mais une recherche à
travers des formes vous allez vous allez
peut-être faire vous faites le vide dans
la tête de l'écrivain qui et comment ce
sont neuf c'est probablement excessif
il faut être excessif et on me dira s'il
faut être excessif c'est une phrase
comme ça en l'air une phrase comme le
steam c'est l'homme est bon rien de ce
qui n'est pas excessif
je n'aime touche qu'on pourrait enfin
bon ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
j'imagine moins volontiers que le projet
d'un écrivain comme le projet d'un
peintre ou le projet d'un artiste en
général c'est d'abord un projet de forme
ce procès de forme bien entendu est en
liaison avec autre chose que la forge et
d'une heure mais le projet de legs est
une tautologie que le projet d'un
artiste c'est le chipset une heure voilà
c'est pas ils croient les banlieues
voilà c'est le projet d'une oeuvre et le
projet d'une oeuvre
exactement comme le peintre pense
d'abord je vais groupe et des lignes
verticales avec une tache rouge ici le
projet d'un écrivain peut très bien être
par exemple je sais pas moi pour
l'étranger de camus je vais écrire un
livre entièrement passé composé est bien
entendu ça va ça va prendre du sens
après mais l'écrivain va être lui même
en train de découvrir le sens peu à peu
au fur et à mesure qui développera une
forme qui lui est apparu comme devant
être fait ce truc sans qu'il sache à peu
près un projet du pain de maurice denis
une toile avant d'être une nature morte
ou une femme nue c'est de l'oeil le
rouge mais je crois qu'en fait ce n'est
pas un grand peintre peut-être avec
cette technique là vous allez mettre à
plat de ce long temps alain robbe
grillet ce qu est ce que vous vous
trouver des affinités avec robert kanter
se critiquer ce que pendant mon os x 10
mai mais ça n'enlève rien n'est ce pas à
sa gloire
je veux dire que c'est pourquoi il vous
paraît démodé allez soyez franc non
écoutez il ya il ya cette bonne vieille
querelle qu'on appelle querelle des
anciens et des modernes j'ai commencé ma
carrière
immédiatement en étant aux prises avec
robert commerce vous faisiez partie le
jury décrite du prix des critiques dans
là c'est une anciens combattants des
prix qui a eu à crier c'est le prix de
la fronde des syndicats cgt en effet
merighetti aux amis leur niveau nous
avons fait déglinguer millauriaux qui
votaient pour robe gris alors bon
immédiatement si vous voulez mon premier
où mon deuxième livre il ya d'un côté
dans un prix cinq contre cinq et milan
viau vous dit robert kelly envie cloître
gras de l'autre côté
blanchot ça c'est pas nouveau
pour mémoire ce que je veux dire c'est
que hill dont nous parlions que ça c'est
de la confusion à sedan le jury dont
nous vous parlions celui du lait du cas
il n'y avait pas blanche au bataillon
mais la goutte et mettons-nous est sûre
c'est ce que je veux dire c'est que 7,7
il y a de la place pour la recherche le
projet quelque chose qui n'existe pas
encore et c
et puis alors il ya d'un autre côté ce
qu'on peut appeler des gardiens de
l'ordre
c'est à dire les enchères c'est un
gardien de l'ordre vie tout à fait tout
à fait d'ailleurs c'est pas du tout on
peut pas songer à lui reprocher le la
critique tel que l'assumé robert quand
elle est une critique de valeur or il
n'ya de valeur que du passé de valeur
que ce qui existe déjà
c'est à dire qu'il y a en somme des
écrivains qui connaissent déjà des
éléments un jugement soutenant sans yao
bo bo est un livre vous créez une valeur
nouvelle comme tout et dort encore le
livre sort la valeur nouvelle et créer
les lation jeu pour vivre dit rien bon
oui je sais que vous parlez de gardiens
de l'ordre
s'il ya un gardien de l'ordre ici c'est
vous et si un gardien de la liberté pour
moi ce contexte vous voyez vous parlez
de l'ordre mais enfin que les l'homme il
tenait le gardien de l'ordre
actuellement dans un certain style de
romans que j'apprécie derrière lui alors
que quand ça sent la barre et ma part y
chantera pas d ont été tellement de
choses dans sa vie et son livre en est
une preuve
c'est un outil à la fois la philosophie
à la fois la métaphysique tout la
littérature avec un good jure t et une
ouverture d'esprit qui pour moi je
viendrai une chose je voudrais une autre
chose c'est que je trouve que son livre
est à faire lire aux jeunes gens
d'aujourd'hui
oui mais chez notre secret c'est une
passion de la lecture une chose qui dure
tout blizz jeune homme mais on dit je
suis à gardien l'ordre sûrement tard
sûrement pas puisque je n'ai pas arrêté
de changer au cou au fur et à mesure de
mes romans
est ce que j'ai réclamés justement
propos le nouveau roman c'était
l'invention permanente du roman c'est à
dire le refus de se figer à des règles
hmm hmm hmm fixé par mois non sûrement
pas
on a alors dit que vous vous être
renouvelée chaque fois est ce que ce
n'est pas une illusion
est-ce que vous est ce que comme tout
écrivain vous ne désirez pas toujours le
même livre
oui en un certain sens bien sur man from
her par exemple ou ton sensible non